we need Christianity in the schools in
the government in the media and yes back
into the churches well listen I have no
problem with Christianity in the
churches as long as no laws are being
broken churches are the right spot for
Christianity Christianity in the schools
if it's a private religious school sure
keep Christianity out of charter schools
that are publicly funded and absolutely
keep Christianity out of public schools
Christianity in government no we we have
separation of church and state we should
have zero zero religious involvement or
influence on civil government you can of
course be privately religious and be an
elected official how would I ever it
would be against the Constitution for me
to say only atheists or agnostics in
government of course not but uh the
influence of that religion on government
as a functioning civil government should
be 0